yeah this is the 32nd ever podcast
episode of the iced coffee hour
i'm gary otherwise known as king pokemon
so far the podcast has made
twenty five thousand eight hundred and
fourteen dollars
beautiful i love that amazing thank you
thank you so much
my pleasure we came all the way to las
vegas today to meet with you
and this is a really special episode
because first of all i would say
first of all would you say you have the
largest pokemon collection
in existence in terms of value uh
not only do i believe that but i know
that as a fact
and i have a lot of items pokemon eyes
in my collection that aren't
even known to everybody that i have
tucked away in northern california in a
storage locker
some people know some of the items but
uh yeah that's a safe assumption
how much would you say the whole
collection is worth let's hook people
from the very beginning this is the
reason why you got to watch this episode
well i've never been able to answer that
question
accurately
i can tell you that what i've brought to
show you
you know i'll give you the value of that
but of
all the things that that we have in
storage i have no idea what the value is
plus
pokemon has been spiking shooting up so
high
that the numbers are changing weekly i
i mean it's uh multi-millions absolutely
but i really can't be more accurate
maybe do you think it's more than 10
million dollars
it has to be yeah i would say that's
safe to say also yes
uh-huh you'll see what we have what we
brought
you know just to show you today wow so
um
oh by the way if you wouldn't mind
putting the mic a little bit closer i
just want to make sure yeah there we go
um so i want to know first of all how
you even got involved to begin with when
did you first discover pokemon
i remember in 1997 or
1998 in that area i remember a news
article that came out that talked about
a cartoon
episode in japan that was causing a lot
of
kids to go into tremors and
hallucinations and things like that i
remember that the seizures
the seizures i remember that it was a
flashing episode
yes and at the time i had my two
uh youngest sons were seven and eight
years old
and so i identified with you know what
was happening to those kids but when i
heard that
i remember my first thought was well
that's pretty cool
you know of course it was serious yeah
right but i thought
i thought man this this made the
international news
you know of a cartoon and so i
investigated what's this cartoon what's
this all about pokemon
uh in in japan of course it was pocket
monsters it wasn't known as pokemon
and and so after you know that that was
my first exposure
then i got interested and then i got
involved in a little bit of a business
venture
on bringing japanese there was no
english cards
bringing japanese cards over for our
shop at home network
and selling them getting them graded and
uh sold on shop at home
which they're somewhere on the internet
there's episodes of that which you can
see
and uh so that they always sold right
out
because pokemon was um you know it was
such an
unprecedented thing in asia that it was
i knew it was a can't miss situation in
the united states because there had
never been anything like it even in
japan
which uh is a good indication of things
that will transfer over so when it got
over here
and then wizards of the coast ended up
having
uh you know getting the license to do
the english version of pokemon
uh i was as involved as i could be had a
lot of doors shut my face but i wanted
to
get in because i knew this was a a great
investment idea
which was my whole intention back then
was as an investment
then my boys got interested in it
and then my neighbors boys and then
suddenly i was driving
out of state to try to find pokemon
cards for my family
and and so uh
and we'd open the packs and then i ended
up with so many we started selling on
something that was yahoo auctions uh
which we don't have anymore there's a
yahoo japan but not yahoo
usa and so we got so many we started
selling them and collecting them
but i've always been a horrible seller
uh
i've always had trouble letting things
go i become so attached
you know to things and and so i
saved them and obviously
that was a smart move to this day you
know that
that i did do that so that was really
the beginnings yeah
what were you doing for work you said
home shopping network so how were you
making your money back then yeah uh well
i've been in the uh casino
management uh business for many years
and uh you know ran the sahara hotel and
uh you know different different things
like that and
and so i at that period of time when
pokemon was coming over
i got sick i got a type of cancer that
had to be treated
and it didn't work no it worked i'm here
today right
so so we ended up uh i ended up
you know with free time you know kind of
like you know a lot of people now during
this covid thing
what they're doing you know they're
finding time to do other stuff
and so i had time to mess with the hobby
with pokemon
and so that's what that's what i did
yeah
that's incredible so um were you
collecting other cards before you
started collecting pokemon yes i
have i'm a lifelong collector going all
the way back to the
1950s i think in 1959 i was five years
old
and i remember saving bottle caps with
uh
professional football players faces on
the inside of the bottle caps
and collecting all the los angeles rams
you know which is where where i lived
and yeah
who my team was and i i collected
trading cards baseball cards
oh absolutely i still have uh a decent
collection not a super valuable one
i don't have any uh mantle rookies or
you know anything like that
right but i do have uh sandy koufax you
know rookies and don drysdale rookies
uh because they were my favorites but
then i didn't keep in the greatest
condition i was just a little kid
you know of course so i collected
trading cards the shows from the 1960s
like adam's family
and monsters i collected all those
trading cards those sets
uh i i like to say
that i don't think there's a single set
that i
either don't own today or didn't own
at one time complete wow so
yeah good question and absolutely i've
collected
my entire life not just those things but
science fiction magazines from the 1920s
uh pulp magazines uh
i mean just so many things but this is
where i think is really interesting
because once you start getting into
what i like to call alternative
investments pokemon cards we could we
could say maybe is one of them
movie posters let's just say like some
of these other things including artwork
are just really unique to start to
collect yes yellow they they absolutely
are and they're
uh i was at a little bit of a
disadvantage early on because my mom and
dad
and family members nobody were was
collectors
they were all if there was something too
much in the house get her to get it out
you know they wanted to keep things neat
and
uh so there was no there was no interest
in collecting so
i really have a feeling it's kind of an
inherent thing
because from the very beginning i was a
collector and loved
you know loved you know the just the
whole thing going to shows the search
the completing sets the it all meant you
know so much inherently to me
naturally and so i i you know it's
you know kind of an individual special
thing and i have it to this day
even with all i've been through all the
things i have uh
i mean i still have my eye forward you
know looking for
you know other things and and and
excited to see other people get things
and
like what you're going to do later on
i'm actually excited to see you do that
to open that
and i mean just because that that's
it's in me you know to you know to be
excited about such things and to enjoy
it yeah so let me share this
so we got uh well i got a first edition
gym trainer's pack unopened what was
that year is that with 1999 i believe
right was it jim trainers or was it 2000
yeah it was that it was actually two
thousand two thousand
it's uh gym heroes jim here yes yes
uh-huh
yeah so unopened i got this pack and
i've been waiting specifically for today
to open it
right well i am so excited to see you
open this because uh
because there there can be some real
treasures in there and every single
you know it's more of a nostalgia thing
you know 20 years ago when you were
you know when you were just a little kid
go to the store and pay your three bucks
for a pack and go out back and open them
i mean that's what it's all about and
that that's what you're going to relive
right this moment yeah
and and i think that's part of the
attraction to pokemon
yeah you know it's it's going back and
it's reliving those memories
see i agree with that and what you were
saying reminds me a lot of myself
because when i was getting into book i
never played the game but i
only collected the cards right and i
kept them in all pristine condition
and uh i got the entire i think i
got nearly the entire base set i i don't
remember how much was first edition or
how much was just base
right i can't remember but someone stole
my entire binder of cards a few hundred
cards
when i was off at school i put them in
my backpack but i would go and bring
them to school to trade
with with other kids and just i'd bring
them and like show them off be like look
what i got last night
and uh i remember i would even trade
with the um
uh with with the store i would go into
and they had a big display of cards and
i'd come in
with my cars like can i trade three of
these that i had duplicates up can i
trade these for
that one that you have there someone
stole it but that
unfortunately really ruined it for me
because i was so disappointed
i was like how could i how could i
recreate that i couldn't so i got into
the neo set because i didn't even
want to go back because like it was so
damaging to me because i think i
was maybe 10 or 11. it's traumatic yeah
it was yes
because i had never had anything stolen
from me ever in my entire life so this
is the first wake up call like
who would steal from me who would do
this yeah so i got into neo
got into magic the gathering a little
bit but nothing was quite the same
afterwards
right unfortunately but you know i hear
i i hear that story quite a bit
uh even today for people just getting
back into the hobby today
if they buy a box and it turns out it's
a reseal or something and
you know it it takes kind of takes the
heart out of you yeah you know it makes
you not wanna
you know you don't wanna take a chance
of having that happen to you again
and and i and i tell everybody that
talks to me about going through an
experience like that
is seriously try to brush it off because
because there was so much value prior to
that day that happened
and that same value is still there at
this moment
get back into it you know do it and
enjoy it and
uh and re relive it you know those
moments they fade away over time
yeah mm-hmm but yeah i also want to
mention but first we have a quick word
from our sponsor simply safe there's
almost always a rise in break-ins during
the holidays and that's exactly why
simply safe is having a huge holiday
sale
u.s news and world report called it the
best security system
in 2020 so whether you all are staying
put or you're traveling for the holidays
i strongly encourage you guys to check
out simply safe
and guys simply safe is great because
you can actually set it up in about 30
minutes and usually with home security
systems it can take
hours to set them up simply safe is just
30 minutes and after that
they'll have your back 24 7 and call the
cops if anything happens
so protect yourself in 30 minutes and
get one free camera when you visit
simplysafe.com
iced coffee and hurry because this deal
expires friday it's simplysafe.com
iced coffee once again everything will
be down in the description
simply safe dot com slash iced coffee
thank you so much and back to the
podcast
my first introduction to you was through
pawn stars i remember i remember your
episodes specifically that must have
been
is that like 13 12 years ago yeah that
was
uh no no no that wasn't that long ago it
was actually uh the early part of 2016.
no wasn't it yeah
yeah doesn't it feel like pawn stars is
way longer no
you see uh pokemon go came out in uh
january i think january of 2016.
and uh and that that kind of drove put a
needle in the arm of a pokemon
and then uh i started getting see i i
was
you know kind of known as king pokemon
for many years before that i did many
things and
was a top you know top ebayer and
did a lot of things prior to that but
the pawn stars episode which was in 2016
just after the pokemon go
craze which lifted it the pawn stars
episode just
lifted it out of sight so it brought the
hobby back
let's talk about that episode for a
second because i didn't fully explain it
when i remember watching your episode
you went into pawn stars and you were
talking to rick was it rick
yes about selling your charizards and
you wanted five hundred thousand dollars
yes for the how many charizards was that
okay uh
do you want the whole story yes please
how do they reach out to you
how much how much can you say how much
of that is like scripted 100
i will tell you the exact honest story
about this
tell us okay they did reach out to me in
advance okay
uh rick lives here in town he's a
neighbor of ours too oh is he really
yeah that would be crazy to meet rick
yeah and
he has some connection to pokemon not
just this episode we did together
but he has some other connections you
know through chumley
in that you know from the show anyway uh
they uh his
his producer did reach out to me and
ask me because pokemon go had lit such a
fire
under the hobby they wanted to get a
pokemon
segment on one of their episodes and so
they reached out to me
and and they had seen one of my listings
that had those charizards and it was
over a hundred
psa tens different types
right but all charizards and all you
know
trading tcg and then there was maybe
20 or 25 becketts cards so it was about
100 120 cards
and so they wanted me to bring those in
and negotiate with rick they said would
i be interested in selling
and all i'm thinking about is what is
this going to do for the hobby how big
would this be
it's always been my focus as to there's
more stories about the past having to do
with this but it's always been about
lifting the hobby even those recent
things with logan
and that and so you know right away i
said oh certainly you know i'll do that
and oh yeah i'll sell
now market for all those at the time
might have been in the 400
000 range uh at least as well as i could
you know figure it a lot of mine were
one of a kind so it's a little hard to
calculate
those because there's no you know well
comps which you would understand in that
so uh i ended up uh
asking for five hundred thousand with
no intention of selling but if they
offered five
you would have sold great question i
would have
been so obligated to sell now
that would have been top retail at the
time yeah
that would have been the the most that i
could ex which is why i set that number
because anything under that i could
easily not accept
had they come to me and said okay we're
going to give you the 500 000
uh which i didn't expect yeah
i i might have had to but i also
might have tried to find a way out did
you have to sign a contract going into
it saying
if they are if they paid you your price
your oblique like like a shark tank
yeah no no i i did have to sign
a contract but it didn't deal with that
you know just dealt with being able to
use my likeness and
yes and that stuff uh and so and so when
that
when he finally said that you know he
wasn't
you know he just didn't know what he
would do with it i mean it's probably
the biggest mistake
pawn stars ever made it's something else
let me mention you might not you might
know this
a lot of people don't it's the second
most
viewed segment in the history of pawn
stars
they've had over 2 000 segments
the pokemon episode that pokemon episode
is the number two highest rated
there's over 12 million already on
history channel
yeah well on history channel then they
had tons at the time
you know what's the top rated uh it's
i feel like that was the car there's
some car no it's actually
some coin something that didn't deserve
it
which we're catching we're catching up
to it's like 15 million
but we we it was 15 million to 10
million at one time on history channel
and now we're 15 million to 13 million
so ours is going we might catch that
but no it was nothing you know special
it was like a coin or something like
that
but uh anyway when he didn't do it i was
relieved because i knew we got the
publicity for the hobby
and uh and yet i you know didn't go
through any type of embarrassment having
to not accept
his uh or later after the show telling
him rick i can't
what percentage of your collection were
those chars
oh okay well that was my entire
charizard collection of course i have a
whole lot of
collectibles with with pokemon you'll
see some
uh but i mean i i was just
that whole thing just worked out so good
because it just blew up after that
episode
it just it just absolutely blew up and a
lot of people got to know me for the
first time so it was
you know good for me not that i try to
benefit anyway you know but
it was good for me like first time you
the first time you did
first time a lot of people did the best
part of it was
it was the first time a lot of parents
saw it
and they have their kids playing with
pokemon and then they see me there with
a half a million dollar
they say wait a sec it kind of
legitimized you know the the investment
values
of pokemon and that they thought well
heck this guy has
you know has this stuff and you know
anyway it
did two things that got parents more
interested in
their kids you know pokemon hobbies plus
for for people who at that time were
turning 25
30 years old it made them think wait a
second where's my old pokemon binder
and then they would go through the attic
they would find their own their own
binder then get back involved see
realize
that you know well this is super cool
you know that you know the feelings
rush back and and so uh it did those two
things also which was great for the
hobby yeah
now let's talk about the hobby now yes
do you worry
or feel like it's a bit bubblish in
terms of prices do you feel like people
are piling in
because they just want the investment
they just want to make money
and do you think that's going to settle
down yeah i
i mean that there there is no more
pertinent question than that
these days because uh it's really hard
to tell
all i can do is give an answer based on
my past experience which i've uh
i have quite a bit with collectibles in
that
uh there i have never seen anything
comparable to pokemon
of all the collectibles that have come
before in my lifetime
i had never seen anything like the
reaction pokemon got
in the origin in 1999 in english
uh all the way through the 2000s up
until today
it's unprecedented so it's really
hard to say i i do understand bubbles
and i have seen
a hundred of them i don't see it
with pokemon because i've always
believed that
10 to 15 years after the last item is
produced
that a hobby is safe pokemon is still
pumping out sets like crazy right
you know they're so these little kids
are growing up with pokemon our little
six-year-old
has pokemon everywhere whether it's
cards or little action figures or
plushes
i mean uh it's it's still there for
these kids and 20 years from now
that six-year-old is going to be 26 and
that
10 year old is going to be you know is
going to be 20
25 30 years old and uh
you know and i see the hobby as being
safe for all those years
once they stopped producing pokemon
uh then i would i could safely say
you know that maybe 10 15 years you know
you know but then again maybe not maybe
it would still keep going
so so you think as long as pokemon is
still
popular to younger people the hobby will
at least these cards could continue
going up in value but once they
stop maybe people might forget
or not be as enthusiastic as they once
were even more so
even more so now than in 1999 because
remember in 1999
us parents didn't have any history with
pokemon
right because pokemon was just being
released in english and so like for my
two boys who were
like seven eight nine at the time
you know i was simply involving myself
with them because i
i wanted to be you know a part of what
they were interested in
today it's a different story when you
guys have kids
you guys already know about pokemon you
guys already enjoyed pokemon
and it's and it's not that big of a
stretch for you to join in
in the in the uh the fun of it you know
with your children
and you actually identify with the whole
thing back then we didn't
because we didn't have pokemon before
that so
yeah yeah i i'd say i'd say that that is
probably the biggest change is that now
the parents know all about it they
they loved it at one time and they're
gonna they will
easily participate with their kids did
you ever get in
to any of the like pokemon copycats
like any of the other collab
collectibles like i know there's like
bacon oh you yugioh like yugioh
i up until 2002 or 2003
i was just an incorrigible collector i i
had to have every trading card set
i have all the dragon ball z sets i have
all the sailor moon sets
the premiere edition i just gave to
steve as a matter of fact the premiere
edition
uh the the yugioh
magic the gathering you know from before
pokemon that came out i think 1993.
uh yeah yeah i collected them all and i
have
uh the vast majority of them still to
this day
and love them and yugioh is taking off
like crazy now too
also another quick question yes when you
first got started in pokemon
how much of it was you looking into a
new investment opportunity
and how much of it was just genuine
curiosity of a new collectible
just because you like collecting things
because it seems like with as much
excitement as there was with pokemon
and the fact that it was just starting
at that time
you could probably properly gauge like
its future values
yeah i i could at the time i had never
seen
anything like uh like 50 to 100 people
in line at a walmart
you know waiting for the next you know
for the night for the jungle release or
the fossil release of pokemon
i had never seen that i mean that that
kind
it was like every single day was black
friday you know it was just crazy
so yes i did i did anticipate i did
anticipate
uh long term investment
you know opportunities with it but
i can't say that i was so smart that i i
uh led my my actions and my life in that
direction
because of the investment opportunities
i'd love to be able to say that
because i would look a lot smarter right
yeah but i i can't take credit for that
because i just simply loved hobbies
loved collecting
loved the connection to my sons yeah and
uh
and i i would have done it no no matter
you know what
you know no matter what the situation
was how much of your own money back then
were you spending on cars like what
percentage of your income were you
making back then
you're like 20 i'm gonna buy pokemon
card like
yeah uh a great question because
i didn't have all the money i had before
and after
because at that during that time period
i had gotten sick
and couldn't work and and it was cancer
it was a type of cancer
and uh and so it wasn't like i was
pumped up you know where i could afford
anything i wanted
in that it's just that it was of such
interest to
jay and devin my two sons that uh
you know every extra dollar that i could
i put into the hobby
and uh of course it wasn't any you know
it wasn't that expensive back then
you could get base packs when they first
came out for like three four bucks
first edition base no first first first
first edition
uh were always difficult to find really
yeah yeah they were always difficult to
find in fact i don't think i ever ever
ever saw one
on a shelf at any store and i was
involved in january 1999 which is the
very beginning
why is that they released them on the
west coast uh
and then they ran out so they never got
across country
but i think the majority of the card
there were a lot of card shops card
shops were super popular back then
they ended up you know getting them and
then breaking them open selling the
singles
and and again people were driving out of
state
including me just to find them that's
how popular so they had no trouble
finding buyers for the singles so they
cracked most of that sealed product
and then sold them through their stores
and the hobby stores had priority
over the walmarts and targets and that
back then
who ended up getting the unlimited
versions in that
so how many unopened first edition boxes
do you think there are still out there
unopened first edition well you know i
have nine
do you know that no i didn't oh oh okay
i did not know that i have a case uh in
the
in the pokemon community the people know
that they've seen pictures and all that
uh there's i have a case of six boxes
where i have the half the lid
opened up like this just because i
wanted to make sure it was inside
uh opened up no boxes would fit you
couldn't take any of the boxes out but i
know
what's inside so that's a box of six i
have a picture
of the picture i can send you uh i just
got that through a
i think it was through frank and sons uh
which is a
collectible uh collect a collectible
uh i don't know what you call a
convention or something but twice a week
in los
angeles uh on wednesdays and saturday
that was 1999.
and they're still going today the frank
and sons show
is still going today in los angeles and
now they have a lot of pokemon
oh i took my boys there every single
wednesday and saturday
and so anyway i got those six in the
case and then i got three odd boxes in
that
those early years how did you acquire
and how much is it
how much how much was that how would you
pay that yeah no
i mean just crazy low amounts you know
may maybe
four or 500 a box something like that or
500 a box
yeah yeah four or 500 for one box so
multiply that for the case of six in
that
i bet back then people were thinking
that was crazy right
oh yeah oh it totally were yeah you
would go into like frank and sons
and on their shelf they would have one
first edition base pack like for 50
and it sat there for six months nobody
would spend 50 bucks on it not that that
exact same pack
you know especially if it's a heavy is
you know
20 25 000 or so but i mean so no no
it wasn't that big of a deal to me it
was kind of a big deal
because i i knew about first edition
stuff you see i was i was no kid
right i knew about the value of limited
edition items
and so you know whereas the the kids
that were into it
they uh they didn't give it much more
than two
thoughts me that first edition stamp
meant a whole lot because it told me
well
these they will never reproduce the
unlimiteds they could
produce forever right so uh
yeah so i i was lucky i had the
experience of what collectibles mean
and what limited editions mean and and
reputable companies putting them out
what it means where they
like with magic the gathering you know
they can reprint those like crazy they
reserve lists and and you know stuff
like that
so uh you know once again i can't really
take much credit it's just simply a
thing that i knew
at the time that i had learned in my
years of collecting
so how many first edition boxes do you
think that there are okay yeah that
uh see we know my nine i might know of
another
you know 20 i don't know anybody with
two but i know a lot of people with one
uh if i had to guess
and again it's purely a guess i would
say maybe
uh 50 to 80 in the world
yeah they just simply weren't available
and there
and there may be less than that the
fewer there are probably the better for
me
because it makes mine a little more
special right um
but i would say 50 to 80 very very
possibly
a lot of people have one yeah are you
ever going to open up
like when you're just leaving them
what's the yeah what's the plan
they're not even they're not they're i
uh
do you know placerville california yeah
it's like north of sacramento
uh that's where they are i have a
storage locker a special security type
storage
you know there that holds all my best
collectibles
and uh i mean i might go up there once
every
two three years uh i would i don't sell
anything out of there
that'll all get passed on when i'm gone
then what's
is that passed on to your children or do
you have the expectation that they're
never gonna sell that
or that it's what's what would you yeah
i know
what do you think
i don't think so if you tell them not
but i'm wondering yeah but why not like
a museum
why not see if you can get some some
publicly funded
or some some museum that you could
donate a portion of
proceeds to charity and display them
absolutely
a lot of that will be going on in fact
it's already drawn up yeah you know as
far as our charities are concerned
uh but the the bulk of it
uh you know my boys will will just
you know have to figure it out in that
but you know that that was my goal from
the beginning you know these these are
if these ever end up being worth
anything you know
any of my collections you know that uh i
hope i've raised
my boys in such a way that they would
value
it themselves or at the very least value
my passion for
it now opening up a museum or something
there was never
really much call for it but i've
actually heard some things recently
where
some some of my stuff and some of the
stuff in the community that
a lot of the guys have is you know very
rare special items that people would
come to see
so that's that's not that could be
something around the corner
i would do that i would pay like 30
bucks to get access to a museum
and you walk in a room like this they're
all like first edition charizards
everywhere like that would be
neat imagine the smithsonian sponsoring
a little like
for for trading cards i think yeah
really interesting right i think it
would be too
i would go too right well i know that a
lot of people would there was a show
about a
about a year ago somewhere in the
midwest where a lot of the guys got
together
uh to put on a show you know where they
could show off their wares
and that and they had a little museum
thing you know set up you know that was
curtained off and that they went in
and they showed a first edition basebox
they showed a psa 10 charizard
they showed some of the japanese trophy
cards and things like that
and and it was it was very successful so
that tells you people do want to go see
this stuff
you know they because they especially
these days where the popularity is
through the roof
yeah so as far as your own collection
have you ever considered
or has your family wanted you to say
we should sell half of this we could
live like
kings we could buy a mansion you could
get whatever you want just
half of it right yeah well i'm kind of
lucky
uh with with tuan she's kind of known as
queen pokemon
or at autism instruct
she has just as much passion for this as
i do
she loves it she had never heard of it
10 years ago because
pokemon wasn't the thing in vietnam uh
but uh in fact it's over 10 years like
12 13 years ago
i saw her turn and look at me so yeah we
should
if she wants we could uh bring her on
for so let's meet her oh okay
tuan come here a minute
come here a minute meeting queen pokeman
yes uh-huh
queen pokemon pokemans yeah come here a
minute hey
come on in come over here say hello yeah
we're we're talking about uh when we met
in vietnam and and you had hadn't heard
about pokemon
at the time you know over there and uh
and yet uh you know we're just kind of
telling our story
at the time he said he had nothing but
he
has a lot of [ __ ] and
he just said come over here visit and
then if five years later you stay here
for five years if five years later you
don't like it
then you can we go five years yeah five
years that's a long time yeah
five years you know by then you're
settled yeah that's why he's
not yes that was when i was kidding what
character you have
he said pokemon card i don't have no
idea
about pokemon cat at that time and then
when i moved here 2010
i saw him like crazy night and day he
everything in it on it said
gary you should sleep sometimes right
no everything pokemon and then 2012
i started to get in it but not
deeply like him because i have another
vision
like you know that autism yeah so um at
that time not autism yet
autism is about uh 2014
so i start to um i even start my
ebay but tell you the truth i sell
um none zero dollar on the ebay and
i close it so i said no no this is not
for me
and i said okay just keep everything
there for me so i put everything
in the stores wow yeah and so
you got her with pokemon most guys would
be like come check out my mansion
i got a car but you should come check
out the pokemon card
yeah i didn't know anything about
pokemon and slowly i know it but not
totally 100 percent
in it but i support him that's nice i
trust
his instant and his love and then
usually
when you love someone yes you love
everything about that person
do you ever get in fights about pokemon
that it's too much
too much pokemon you tell them i didn't
have
instagram and recently i start in the
rams is that
you have to spend time with your family
daddy
and and then when i sign up instagram he
bum he said
my wife in he posted one of my boss i'm
supposed to say my wife just get into
interim just say follow her something
and the next morning i saw
what 400 people four hundred years ago
when people you know what's your
interest what's your instagram
everyone who's watching go go follow her
let's let's do this
people here seventy thousand yeah yeah
yeah yeah you guys just go to instagram
is
uh autism instruct okay and then autism
instruction yes and it's instruction
autism instruction and it's for a good
cause
helping charity yes autism i think this
is good so
guys just do it let's do it and then and
then
i say oh my gosh this is what you spend
time for
you love and then i fell in love oh i
was the director of a resort
casino hotel right on the south china
sea
and uh tuan was hired to be the
assistant director
plus she spoke multiple languages which
i needed because very few people spoke
english there
and uh and so we fell in love and i told
her just come back for that five years
and and if you as big as my sons my sons
yeah my sons would be uh my sons would
be
were like 14 15 they'd be 19 20.
and then i'd feel okay about going i
said and if you're not happy after five
years
i'll go with you back to vietnam and
i'll live there the rest of my life
all right and i was i do what i say you
know pawn star's promise
try to get out of it yeah yeah well
contract though
those things started happening and like
tuan was in that episode too but she was
one of the crowd
they brought they brought you know some
people in you know from the yeah to be
in the episode
you know as customers in that but yeah
fortunately after
that five years she had gone to unlv
gotten another degree and then wanted to
start other things
had the baby and and then decided
you know you know that she wanted to
stay and i went
because i would have left yeah just like
i probably would have had to have sold
to rick
right because i told him i would yeah uh
but
i i got it working your face i have yes
yes yeah which would change everything
but it's good because you would have
honored it so you deserve it i like
deserved it you've done it
yeah i mean it just happened that the
cards were in your favor
right that's true that's a good way to
put it the cards were in my favor
you know what i think i think you're
good luck so how about this
let's open up the pack oh jack how about
this what i'm thinking jack if you want
to get some uh
just some b-roll yeah yeah i don't have
any sleeve so i'm planning to put the
card back
in here but if we get a first edition
uh blaine's charizard or an erica's
venusaur we're gonna go crazy here
okay so we got brock's geodude
erica's weep and belle
energy stars manky
bellsprout magnamite
sabrina's abra oh we got a blaine's
charmander that's good oh that's a sign
of something to come oh let's see rocket
snorlax
wow not hollow but still i guess it's uh
i missed it from the back i guess with
these is it so it's not three from the
back on this one
there's another card behind that one no
misty-seeking
uh-uh oh there's not no it was the
rocket snorlax okay that was
so okay not uh not a hollow
but we still got a blaze charmander it's
uh
probably a nine it's a little off center
but the uh
what do you think of this the rocket
snorlax
that's the rare nice did it
i think too we should see what's in your
uh
what's in your briefcase okay also to
throw this out there we haven't
mentioned this we are filming
in las vegas at steve aoki's house the
dj
because gary and him are friends so we
arrived at this house and i have to say
it is
now i i feel like he keeps saying this
is the coolest house i've ever been to
ever since i started hanging out with
graham but now this is definitely the
coolest house i've ever been to
right what house did we oh no it was the
um the one with kevin o'leary it was the
one with kevin o'leary yeah and then
also it was the one that we did with
christine
that was like this between all the
houses this is by far the nicest it has
a
jump like ball pit or something like a
foam trampoline and ball pit
yes literally everything anyone could
ever want is all within this house and
it's a very very
nice house as well yeah and you guys
took advantage of that too
absolutely some pictures up here yeah we
had a fantastic time so steve thank you
so much for
for doing this yes so how much is in
how much is this worth this box
you want to guess yeah yeah i want to
take a guess so you said you have multi
you said over 10 million no no no over
10 million means
means my entire pokemon collection you
have all the
this is just a small part of it a yeah
so
all your good stuff's up north so i'm
going to say in
in that briefcase i feel like i'm going
to say something low and it's going to
be stupid
to be honest just be honest don't don't
don't try just be what you really think
it is
what i really think that is yeah oh my
gosh
uh one point
six million dollars i was gonna say two
okay it's about double those those
numbers
yeah there's i i actually uh knowing
that we were going to discuss this today
i actually checked current market values
of what i could sell these for within
seven days
if i if i was gonna sell them what could
i get within seven days so
these are not outrageous numbers these
are sellable these are what they would
sell for
quickly mm-hmm in that and it amounts
to do you want me to open this would
tell us how much
and then i got one question for you
before you open it okay it amounts to
3.9 million dollars
inside this case and uh it's not a huge
case but
it is some of the most special items i
have how do you ensure this that's what
i want to know
you don't it's not insured it is not
insured can't you get this insured
there's got to be someone who's willing
to ensure yeah there there are some
collectible
uh some companies that will ensure
collectibles
but put yourself in the
in the uh place of an insurance company
that are is trying to ensure these
uh how easy it would be to take
advantage of
an insurance company i mean these are
just little cars right
you know i could i could say right now
you know
well i'm missing three cards you know a
million dollars
i'm missing three what's what's going on
here right so they are not that
open to uh insuring collectibles
like this uh there are a couple
companies that do
they are so outrageous and the
restrictions are are so confining
that uh there's
[Music]
nobody with half a brain would would
take advantage
so how do you protect against these
either being stolen
or damaged okay what i what i did to get
these ready for you
was the majority i took out of one of my
safety deposit boxes at
bank of at our bank and uh which i have
a
decent size box where i keep the most
expensive things
yes you can you can insure things
through uh
bank safety deposit boxes but there's
little reason to
if there's a safe place those that's the
safe place
and the one i have has special
restrictions on safety deposit boxes
it's not your normal uh system
bank system uh in other words i am a
hundred percent confident
nobody could ever get into that and and
they're
100 safe and then the balance of them
i just keep in the storage i have a
couple storage lockers here
in las vegas also i keep them here
and uh you know inconspicuously not in
my name
you know because people can research my
name uh
in fact that was uh you know some
i think i think it was steve aoki's
business manager
who gave me that advice said take
everything out of your name all your
storage lockers don't use your name
don't use
tuan's name at autism
instruct yeah
follow like you say and smash the like
button destroy it right yeah destroy the
because of the uh youtube algorithm yes
uh so uh i i keep those in the storage
locker
and very inconspicuous and uh
and so i i feel you know very confident
with that too
because i got i got steve's manager he
he set me all up to do things properly
good and yeah so well let's see what's
in here
i'm uh really excited for this okay
jack this is going to be the most
expensive thing that you've seen
oh no maybe christine's ring
1.6 million dollars jack held it and how
much did you guess it was worth like
50 grand 300 grand she says
yeah she says 1.6 and his face you could
you could
pause you could actually put this up
here freeze frame on your face
as she tells you the thing it's just
this
it's it's priceless graham has
introduced me to a pretty
yeah different lifestyle yeah uh we have
this thing where just jack reacts to
things
so and and because yes you have such
genuine reactions to everything
it's just this utter amazement it's
really fun it's just it's just fun
all right let's see this okay i'm
wondering if i should uh
b-roll some of this should we do this
before afterwards uh we could do it
afterwards you sure okay
okay
now there's i feel like yeah numerous
different things i don't know how you
want to show this
um let's do it afterwards yeah okay
yeah we'll do b-roll afterwards you
should i i don't want to touch anything
you you show us and well you can touch
really it's all protected yeah can i
grab one
anything of course sure
so this is a shadowless gem mint 10
charizard
yeah market value that's not first
edition correct no it's not
okay so uh market value for those
i know uh you know one of the guys that
we all know in the community just paid a
hundred and twenty thousand for one of
those
wow jack do you wanna be so careful with
that
no no no no no oh you could take it you
could throw it across no you floor one
no how was it how was it can i grab one
more everything how is it
how is it so protected in there that it
if i threw it i'm not going to but
it wouldn't move around and damage at
all no no is it
so protected it totally totally sounds
it's one of the reasons for
uh for grading cards for a lot of people
it's just to give them you know life
lifelong protection and that's how maybe
maybe you want to drop it off the roof
thousand dollars that's minimum 100 000
you can get a little more than that yeah
wow
those are shadowless psa 10
did you grade these or did you buy i
bought
of the shadowless i would say you know
over these years
maybe i graded i think there's 12 of
them in there
and i think i graded half and bought
half
maybe take these these are all
shadowless
i don't know how much we got oh you know
what i got i got to get a picture with
with all of these
we gotta get pictures we gotta get
pictures gotta get pictures okay
oh my god that is insane so wait wait so
how much am i holding
how many is this one two three four five
six seven eight it's a million bucks
you want to hold a million dollars jack
pokemon cardboard
my hands are my hands are sweating
because i want to make sure like nothing
happens to this
i'm so worried i'm still worried about
it if you don't juggle them
juggle with them you could probably
juggle with them and be okay too
oh
they're all first edition gem mint tens
six of them i will get pictures
afterwards i really want a picture right
now
there's a little speck right there
yeah uh gem mint 10 doesn't mean perfect
you know of course yeah if you know the
process to make these these all come on
big
sheets the sheets get fed off of each
rollers
roll and peel the sheets off cutters
come and cut the edges
on those yeah do you have any that are
like basically perfect
what would you say the most perfect one
is here let's
you know what i i would that that right
there that might
that might bore you because i would have
to go very closely through those with a
mag with my uh you know special magnify
jewelers loop and
some are a little better than others wow
this is it man that's the one
this is a bgs
10 signed yes
in this case the signature means very
little
yeah arita who did design that charizard
uh and it's signed on the case not the
card right
i mean never would you let him sign that
card
because that's extremely special who
signed this uh arita
yeah the artist yeah but which in a lot
of cases that's a big deal
but this card is such a big deal his
signature means nothing
yeah i i could take i i i'm tempted to
take it off
of there it's just on the case it's not
on the card
the signature i see unfortunately this
for centering for this not to get a
black label it's the top is just
a fraction i know too tall that's
it now this card is the one you
mentioned lee and i
leon hart and i went to beckett's i
wanted to get this uh
crossed over to a black label all tens
yeah and i gave it to them and they went
through it and they said i'm sorry we
just can't
you know we it's a ten it's a pristine
10 but we can't upgrade you on that it's
a shame that they can't just
file down that top just a little bit i
know you wouldn't even want to touch
this card
not not if you knew how much that's
worth do you think this is
the only one in existence now there are
three of those
in existence three uh beckett's
gem pristine tens i own two of them
i had the only two up until about three
four months ago
only two in the world
and somehow somebody came up with one
graded it through becketts and the third
one came out
nobody knows who it was we don't know
who it was i'm trying to find
them in fact i've offered i've offered
50
000 to anybody that can find me the
third one of those
and that i can complete a transaction to
own it
so i own the only three wow and nobody
has come forward
yeah now if you check this the uh serial
numbers the cards before it
and the cards after it are like it was a
binder set it's like
somebody had a binder took the cards out
all first edition and had him graded
and by chance and by luck they ended the
charizard ended up with a pristine 10.
but the other ones were sixes and sevens
so
you could tell that this was no pro who
got it
so it could be just some random person
got it
i will never find out who it was it'll
stay hidden
you know essentially forever at least as
far as i'm concerned
how much is that card worth okay let me
guess
jack guess how much you think that that
one card is worth yes
i thought a 10 was worth 300 grand not a
becket beckett is like you have psa
but then you have back it's like the
rolls-royce psa
i would say is like the mercedes of
grading
this is the rolls royce this is like you
take a psa
you put a psa under a fine tooth comb
and then you get back it
there's a hundred and twenty one of
those psa tens
in the world 121 psa 10
of the psa 10. that's a beckett
there's three of those there's 121
of the psa tens so that gives you a
little better idea
that is the tens of the tens it's like
the top one percent or the top
point one percent there you go you
guessed first i'll get second
now you can't be wrong because one has
never sold
because i would never sell them and the
other one's never
shown up so this is all guesswork
i feel like if it's the rolls-royce to
mercedes equivalent
i'm gonna say one million dollars
yeah i would say if if the
tenant i would say this is probably
worth up to
two million dollars the right collector
i'd say two million i would be i
i would have to agree to that
price that's an awful lot i'm there is
no right answer to this
if i had to put a number like you guys
just did
i would say maybe 800
000 to a million yeah would you pay a
million dollars for one of those
that's a good question oh man
[Music]
you don't want to tip your hats
i offered for anybody who could find
that third one for me
i offered 750 000
and 50 000 finders fee so that would be
my
maximum why really kind of do i really
you know it would be too hard to do more
than that
would be hard to do that what's your
advantage of getting all three besides
just having the market
just because all these years i had the
only one
right for many years i had the only one
then a second one popped up
and with leon hart's help as a middle
heat middleman for me in dallas
he found it got the girl to agree to
sell it i flew to dallas we completed
that transaction
he did a video on it with him and i
uh okay see that's interesting i don't
mind uh
because of because of the girl i can't
say the exact amount but i can say
under a hundred thousand i paid for it
and that's
four or five years ago or something like
that uh
[Music]
so i had the only one and then this one
came and i bought this one for under a
hundred thousand
that gave me the only two and so i've
always had the only ones
right now this third one came did you
hear about the third one
uh it uh beckett's advertised it
you know they advertise you know that
this card is shown up and
they put it on the front page of their
website and
so okay now those are
so you got the base yeah those are the
edition yeah those are the uh
the the family of those guys those are
the first edition
uh hollows that came with
that first edition base set that's all
nine and a half's yeah those are all
nine point fives do you have any tens no
of the base no have you wanted tens of
the base no
not real not beckett tens why harder
than how expensive
very very hard very hard those i mean
you figure three of those in the world
and anybody who has one of any quality
is getting it graded
right right there's no none hiding away
and
at least not likely that's a beauty huh
wow what do you what's the blastoise
worth
the blastoise what are the sub grades
nine and a half's all four that's a
beautiful one
yeah that's uh that's a saw that would
be equivalent to a psa 10.
oh yeah so maybe uh 30 000 something
like that
so what's the what's off on the
centering on this one
uh well like graham said he saw just a
little tiny
bit of an off top to bottom i think you
said graham yeah i think the top is a
little bit sure about that
but that's the main reason i sent it
back in to hopefully get it upgraded to
a black label 10 10 10 10.
right now it's 10 10 10 9.5 but they
said the same thing they said the same
thing
you got to wait till they like recycle
their employees yeah have you thought
about that
just keep sending it and sending it
until eventually keep trying
someone else yeah so they know yeah it's
such a it's such a famous
card that they would know what i'm doing
yeah because they they know
they know me but you know what couldn't
you have do it under someone else's name
only because the card they all know the
card is mine
i'll take the card out you take the card
out under another person's name
no too risky it's very risky no they
don't take it out when they uh
when they uh re-re-grade it unless
it qualifies for an upgrade then they
take it up
so it's too dangerous it's too too
i really don't even know what to compare
that to if you're trying to cut it and
like one of those little plastic
chards hit the card and cause a little
scratch
suddenly you're that could be like 83
right that well no that could be a
difference between
eight hundred thousand dollars and sixty
thousand dollars
yeah that a little so that's why
as long as they're in there again i
wouldn't care what you guys did you guys
could
play catch with them they're they're
good they're safe
but once you start cracking them open
it's dangerous what do you think the
gyarados
this is the card that i uh pulled uh-huh
and unfortunately oh yeah that's what
you pulled on the live stream yeah
there's a little tiny white nick on my
like
tiny tiny tiny little speck on that side
otherwise center is good what would
what's this card worth that would put it
to a nine probably and that would
probably
i don't know maybe well for a 10 it's
probably
about 10 000 if it gets a psa 10.
yeah for a for a nine it would be
one or two thousand maybe oh and then
what you you have packs in here these
are all first edition base packs
wow and you have no desire of opening
these
what if what if there's a uh bgs10
charizard in there i know i know
sometimes
when i go to bed at night i that's my
first dream
you know is what's inside there it's so
hard
there's uh 26 of those packs here
is that a heavy pack uh there's eight
heavy packs
out of the 26 so there's eight packs
that
do have a holo foil inside
and that's that could be
zero charizards that could be one
charger it could be two charizards
right statistically it would be one
though right statistically
it would be uh about half
about a 50 percent chance of there being
a charizard
out of those eight packs about a 50
chance be even a little bit less because
i think you have 12 in a box
12 hollow foils in a box and uh
the chance for a charizard uh out of
those
there's 15 hollow foils possible
12 hollow foils in a pack means you're
not even guaranteed a hollow foil out of
a full box
you're guaranteed 12 hollows out of the
15 possible hollows
and then some of those hollows can be
duplicated you might get two or
something you might get three or
something
could you ever get two hollows in one
pack i got oh no
no not in one pack but in one box one
time
i got three charizards
in one box this was before that this was
like 2005
and i do have two witnesses that had
happened one was my youngest son
devin and uh the other one was
it was a business partner joel who's
still alive lives in columbus ohio
and he would attest for it so because
they were both there watching me open
this box
three first edition bass charizards
that's not the whole story
all three graded psa 10. oh my god and
i'm saying that
with people alive that saw me do it
right
so what do you think yeah what are those
first edition packs worth
okay uh
they're worth depending how you sell at
light if you sell a light pack
maybe eight to ten thousand for a light
pack that's pretty much guaranteed
no holo foil if you sell a heavy pack
where you're guaranteed a heavy like out
of those eight
of those uh then about 25 000
for a guaranteed hollow pack and if you
sell them
unweighed which means right now you just
grab one and buy it
and open it then i would say right in
the area of
15 to 18 000. it's that much yeah
i remember when logan announced his
packs for 11
000 bucks yes i did the research on i'm
like these packs are really worth
nine right and i'm like i'm paying a
premium for the shout out from logan yes
but i think well it's good i can make a
video from it so i can make it worth it
at least there you go
um it's crazy to see how much the values
have gone up
yes yeah i mean it's it's real
it's real safe to say that uh
like with logan with your thing that you
that you did
at that time he had just bought a first
edition
psa 10 charizard for 150 000.
so now that same card that come out of
those packs
is 350 000 right so obviously
now that price that you guys paid
uh it would have to be more than that
today because the price of the
cards especially that charizard is so
high
like had you not broke that pack the one
you have
you could have sold that heavy pack
because you could have weighed it
with the gyarados that would show up as
heavy easily sell it for 25 000
maybe 30 000 on ebay there's trying to
get 40 000.
yeah i think the curiosity for me to
know what's inside i couldn't do it
i'll i'll tell you that whole experience
i think was worth it yeah
yeah yeah it was a great experience yeah
i loved watching you guys i
i loved watching that yeah and yeah
if you had to pick a second favorite
card what would it be
my absolute favorite pokemon card
is venusaur it's not charging it's not
charging
there's something about the looks of
that base set
venusaur you know something about the
nose
the nose on the artwork that that just
for me just makes me want to grab that
nose and shake it you know it's just so
cool
the artwork on the green which is my
favorite color and
and the the look of on his face and the
and the bulk of his nose it's uh
when that when that first came out
that's been my favorite card ever since
so base said venusaur artwork even
the erika's venusaur i think you
mentioned earlier i love that venusaur
too but the base said venusaur
is my favorite card and then i would
have to say the charizards
what would you say for people who want
to get into collecting
let's say it's both a hobby and an
investment is it worth it for people to
buy like
psa sevens and sixes and eights or is it
worth it to save up and get
one good like psa 10 instead of a whole
bunch of sevens
i'm the the tens have
escalated so much that it really is out
of reach
you know for the majority of people
those are really out of reach
and with that being the case they're
going to be
liking the nines and getting the nines
the nines are getting scarce
then they're going to be liking the
eights i'd like as an investment
opportunity
i like the lower graded ones the sixes
sevens and eights
because eventually those higher grades
are going to
fade out they're going to disappear
people are going to get them in their
collections like me
and not release them not not give them
up
so i i like i like the idea of premium
cards like these
in lower grades very much so you think
that would be a good investment
yeah i do but now but but you're saying
if someone had the money
yeah to buy a higher grade to go with
the highest grade you could afford
because it's that curve the higher the
grade all of a sudden it rises
exponentially
yes yeah uh if my let's let's just say
money isn't as much of an issue then i
would go with the higher graded cards
okay
yes i would because any time you look at
a graph
of value changes in that
uh you see the the middle grades going
up a little bit
and if you see spikes it's always those
psa tens that show the spike
yeah so yeah and and you know i wanted
to ask you something
if i could don't yeah anything whatever
you want because uh
you know i was thinking let me grab one
of these
i was thinking that you know for
investment opportunities
uh of course you know we know each other
i know that you have rental properties
and stuff like that
uh you
in los angeles are they might be more i
don't know but say 750
000 home you can buy fix it up a little
bit
do your 50 000 thing and then rent it
out and all that
or you can buy for that exact same 750
000 this instead of a house you're
buying
this slab this card obviously upkeep and
everything is different i know that's
probably all
yeah i'm shooting through your head
right in that
what do you think investment wise
because a lot of what you do is foreign
and yet equal val today if they were
equal value today
how how do you feel about that what
would you it's tough because i feel like
with the
investment property you're guaranteed a
certain roi that you could go in and see
okay
see all these houses are selling at this
price i know if i put 50 000 in i could
come out with a hundred thousand equity
it's going to run for this price
i'm making this month's it's it's
guaranteed when done right
there's very little risk with this the
issue that i see with this
compared to rental property is that
you're not guaranteed
income and it's hard to leverage this
and it's hard to
borrow against this it's hard to go to
this card to the bank and say
i want to borrow 300 grand i want to do
a cash refinance so i can go move my
money around
this is a lot more illiquid good point
that's that's the biggest difference i
see
this is really interesting to me because
i feel like
you could make more money i think with
pokemon but it's just
the risk you take the risk that
you're not going to be able to replace
your income from this
it's it's kind of it it reminds me i
don't want to
compare it to uh to to bitcoin let's
just say but it's
similar in that you can't borrow against
it
right and you're going to do with the
expectation that someone else is going
to pay more
now i think with this i think just the
rarity alone is worth
something it's just that that's
it's it's giving up something guaranteed
for something that has the potential of
outperforming anything else i see so the
it's because it's a little
little bit or quite a bit more
speculative yeah
it's that that takes away from some of
the current value of it
yes from from a utility standpoint
it's hard to go to the bank and say i
want to pull a credit line from this
and then buy stocks you couldn't do it
it's just getting appraisal done and
within a week they give you a credit
line or with stocks
it's instant right they'll just say
what's your portfolio value they have a
calculation stocks okay we'll lend you a
million bucks
right so with this it's harder
um would you say that also with most
collectibles
yes so i don't think it's just actually
pokemon you think that's collectibles in
general
in general mm-hmm but i think same thing
yeah same thing um what was i just about
to say
um reminds me of uh like uh
dubai low license plates like if you get
a license plate that just says three or
two or seven
oh you're selling millions of dollars
now okay yeah
low digit license plates in dubai that's
the ultimate sign of wealth is when
someone has a low digit license plate
because they had to pay top dollar for
that
very interesting but this this is what i
feel like
because like i i'm so because now i want
one like really bad
yeah dude
because i see like that's uh no i i
wouldn't sell any
did you buy one graham you could find
one oh no
no you know knowing that the last one
sold for 358
000 that's a record high you would have
to match that
or go a little bit above it yeah i mean
i you
you know what i have and i think that's
overpriced
and i and yet i own them i'm affecting
my own values by saying that
because a lot of people listen to me
right about this
uh i think 358 000
is excessive and i don't think they're
worth that
i don't think they're worth 250. what
what honestly yeah what i'm concerned
about
is the logan paul video
exploded the hobby and you have so many
people going after these cards because
they see it going up in value so fast so
they're all jumping into it
right paying top dollar just because
they want to get it yes and i think
a few years from now some of that's
going to simmer down it's going to
settle
and it's going to stay there until the
next thing comes up i think it reminds
me a little bit of like
the bitcoin thing where it seems like
every seven years got boom
it just explodes goes down settles
there's a new base
something else comes along boom same
thing even higher next time
goes down settles that that's what i
think maybe could happen you know what i
i couldn't agree more okay and i think
the worst time to buy would be today to
buy a psa 10 first edition charizard
because i totally agree with you two
three years from now i think they're
going to go back down where they belong
which is probably in the 200 000 range
i mean i i'm not really gambling much by
saying that because i'm not going to
sell mine anyway
10 years two years doesn't make any
difference but my honest feeling is
exactly the same as yours
wait today two three years from now
they're going to be where they belong
and then pick them up and then it could
go through it natural
now from 1999 to this day these have had
a gradual increase
they have never the charizards have
never
leveled off or gone down they have all
had a
a proper increase every day for the last
21 years
never changed this spike that happened
is sudden
and unexpected and uh
but yeah like if it weren't for the
logan paul video where do you think
these would be trading at because before
that video
these at the top were selling at like 40
50.
yeah they i think once sold for 72
uh publicly i know of some that sold
privately
prior to logan paul uh purchase
uh in the all of them under 100 000 in
that
uh but i got many offers
for a hundred and thirty thousand yeah
now since
since this is like a podcast about
investing and stuff like that
you said that you'd be willing to spend
750 or 800
total thousand dollars in order to get
uh i'd have to borrow from you guys
but yeah i would do that
[Laughter]
charizard is collateral how are you
getting those
funds like how does that let's talk
about
building wealth and how you have built
your wealth through pokemon cards
throughout time
yeah well i'm very i'm very pokey rich
very pokey rich not rich just pokey rich
just pokey rich pretty much
uh of course i've worked my whole life
and i've worked hard my whole life i've
saved up a little bit
uh but then just about
all my money i put into my collectibles
and you know certainly if i were to sell
off collectibles i would do well
uh but then you know then again i can
tell you
you know another interesting story you
know maybe
privately you know about that you know
that situation
but uh because
pokemon has been you see i'd say 80
percent of my collectibles
in my storage lockers that i work so
hard and love them so much
are absolutely worthless right i mean
the
no value whatsoever you know like fallen
empires
you know trading cards and things like
that that i work so hard to put together
in that
they just simply haven't you know gone
up at all and most of them have dropped
down to nothing they're not worth
anything
uh so a lot of that those efforts i put
it just so happens that pokemon has been
extremely successful and that was what i
concentrated on for
you know 20 years so a lot of the
a lot of the you know expendable income
i have why i could buy that card for
that price now
is because of what pokemon has done and
i sold
some things that are of less consequence
to me so you still
sell cards and that's how you're able to
oh yeah
yeah but every everything is done
privately now i do it through friends
right
in that i don't sell i think on ebay i
think i have two listings
that are absurd about things
i don't sell anywhere except privately
like you know through logan or steve or
you know you know just through friends
and if you don't mind answering this
sure how much of your net worth is in
pokemon cards what percentage
you don't have to say an exact number if
you're uncomfortable saying that no i
mean i i would have a pretty good idea
i i would i would say i would say
probably with these spikes and values
i would have to think my pokemon
collection takes up at least 80 percent
of my total net worth
and i wouldn't have said that a year ago
you know it might have been like 20 30
yeah 30 40. and what about uh
investments like real estate and other
stuff like that do you invest in that or
is it
more so just alternative that's an
interesting thing i i
have never invested in real estate you
know ever
i've owned homes in the past
our last home we owned here in henderson
was in a retirement community
uh and then the little girl came along
our little daughter came along and we
had to move out
of that that was actually the last home
we purchased you know was that one
uh so i don't have any uh real estate
investments at all right now
we are looking for a house now though uh
that i can also explain to you later on
yeah wow is there
is there under any condition that you
would sell the first edition charizard a
psa 10 yeah i wouldn't
uh only because only because
i sold two mainly for the good of the
game the good of the hobby plus i love
the shadowless the most
i and i have double the number of
shadowless
in that and i think the shadowless i i
are
rare and i think overall i think they're
a better investment than first edition
why is that there's 121 psa 10
first edition charts there's only 54
psa 10 shadowless charizards and yet
there were more
char shadows charizards produced but
don't you think that's just because
people haven't graded
the shadowless cards because they felt
like it's not as excellent question
excellent question but absolutely not
because if you look at the nine
populations
the nine populations are much higher for
the shadowless than they are for first
edition
if you get my drift yeah see in other
words the
uh the number graded are very similar
but the numbers that got tens and also
people collected like me first editions
and then when the unlimited series came
out the shadowless
those went into people's decks and they
started playing them
in that so the shadowless ones were the
first unlimited
nobody knew there was going to be a
shadowed version afterwards
so those got played with and damaged and
so i think that's the main reason
they're rarer
and there's fewer so if you were to pick
one card
that you see graham you should go and
buy this card invest in it i think 10
years from now you'll you'll do
better than seven percent a year let's
say which card would you pick
i would pick the shadowless charizard
what about a first edition venusaur
do you think maybe the venus or
blastoise might
do well or you really think the
shadowless you know the spike
the spike see we're we're talking
as we're you know right in the middle of
a spike in pokemon
and it's kind of like you know when when
your housing market
you know reaches the top where
everything is more expensive than it's
ever been before
and you know brentwood and beverly hills
you know these different areas they're
all up 150 200 percent
and then you get asked you know where
would you recommend
should i buy in bellar bent you know uh
brentwood or
it'd be hard to answer that because
they're they're all at their all-time
highs and so
i don't know i mean i could be wrong
about that but that's the kind of the
way
i see it i i don't think it's it's that
smart
buying things when they're at the top
that they've ever been
because how much higher are they going
to go yeah that charizard 358
000 that's absolutely insane
it's not worth that what do you think
the base charizard
is worth today versus what it should be
worth space
unlimited base unlimited psa 10. okay
yeah that that's a that's a really good
one because i
i have 52 psa 10
unlimited charizards isn't that the
entire
psa market no there's there's more wait
how many psa
10 unlimited is it i i'd have to i
haven't looked in a long time maybe
400 500 maybe something i have to double
check
but there uh a year ago a psa 10 was
probably worth about 1500 2 000. now
they're probably worth 10 to 15
000. so they've gone up 10 times in one
year
and that's this card rate no that's not
those are we're talking
uh base unlimited shadowed god again
shadow lists yeah yeah well yeah well
these are a whole different
okay i think those were maybe 30 000 a
year ago and now they're
over a hundred thousand that's over a
hundred thousand really oh wow
what do you think it should be i could
take your phone right now
and i could sell every single one of
those for a hundred thousand
before we finish this interview it's
absolutely
the right price today why do you uh
continue buying these cards and
continuing the collection that
you already have so much of um
it's an illness maybe maybe we
need a dr phil here or something i you
know i don't
i don't know why it's it's a good thing
i did
and it's a good thing i do because it's
made an awful lot of money
if i were to liquidate if i were to sell
uh
i don't know why i want more why do i
want that third one like you asked me
before
i don't know why well it makes sense why
you want the third one because then you
would have all three
have them all then you would have the
market right but but buying something
that you wouldn't own 100
of yeah yeah i
i don't know i'm i just want them i just
you know love them so much and the more
i have the happier i am
do you have any other like expensive
tastes or anything
you uh do you drink starbucks
i not in a million years would i do that
and i'm not saying i i'm as smart as
graham
uh you know when it when it comes to
frugality and that
uh but i love the way he is
you know when i see those things and i
see when you talk about dates
oh yeah i mean that that's me what
you're saying is exactly what i want to
be
and exactly what i want to do and i
think it's so cool
in that but then oddly with with
spending and that
with tuan or with little accara
i spent every nickel in my pocket and
and i would and i would just be so happy
about that my heart is absolutely what
graham
is what he what he had what you advocate
in that
but when it comes to those two girls i
mean if
just next time when you're at my house
i'm going to show you
her toys and i mean it's almost like
every day i have to buy her a toy
because i want her to be happy i want to
see that smile i want to
that means more to me but my nature
is to be very frugal my nature is to try
to be very smart
you know with my money and before we got
married
i was very good with my money you know i
starbucks you know
five six seven dollars for a coffee is
absolutely insane it doesn't make any
sense at all
in that i don't think it makes sense to
anybody i think it's a laziness
thing they don't want to make the coffee
so they go and they they do it
but is there value to that to those well
we would consider wasting money
there must be value to them yeah it the
experience must have some value
right when you think yeah yeah because i
don't feel that way you know i
i feel differently but the experience
for the two girls i totally feel so
it's almost like a split personality
yeah i think let me just change the
battery yes
yeah sure yes thank you so much for
coming on the podcast it was
amazing having you and uh nice to meet
you as well
i i want to say like this is probably
one of the funnest
podcasts we've ever done because i'm
trying to think back
stradman was fun but we were doing so
much other stuff that day that by the
time we filmed the podcast exhausted
we had a full day uh
this this is i think our most this is my
favorite one
if i were to go back for any podcast can
you think of i mean i don't know if i
want to pick out
like based off the guest individually
but just overall the overall podcast
experience
this has been a great experience we came
to vegas the drive over here was a
breeze you wouldn't say this is your
favorite one
well just because i don't want to put
down other people i don't know
kevin's was great yes kevin this has
been
i will say this you want to say top
three yes i will say top three top three
i i want to say so far this has been my
favorite experience because of how
different
it has been from every other episode and
syncs
all of this together getting able to
talk to you i would say it's the best
one yes
he said he said this is the best thank
you
yeah yeah we met steve aoki that's
amazing uh and we got to see this just
collection and and
talk to i i think the the best person
when it comes to pokemon
oh thank you yeah thank you so much
thank you really it really means a lot
and by the way
we we all got uh the illness tested we
don't want to say the the c word
oh that test they do that little thing
up uh
up your nose that was actually not my
favorite no
that was a scary that i've never had
that done before either
uh has never had it done either uh every
time we always get the
finger that's what we were expecting or
like it's cvs they do the
just yeah that's what i think that that
that thing was weird
you know i haven't i've never none of us
had that it was scary yeah
it was scary i hated that but uh so
we're all good
we're all negative which is great uh
thank you so much again
oh thank you you know i appreciate you
guys so much
you know doing this the the financial
side of things
you know just isn't brought up enough
with collectibles and with uh
especially with pokemon information
i think a lot of people should go to
your channel and check out your
financial information and how it
can apply to their collectibles because
you have a lot of these young people
that are sitting suddenly on tons
of money because they're psa 10 lugia
that was worth 13
000 eight months ago yeah today it's
worth
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
suddenly these
these kids got a hundred thousand
dollars extra in their hand
and they honestly aren't prepared to
know what to do with that
so i i think uh i think you know you
shedding some light on that and even
maybe in another video talking about
you know when you suddenly come into he
hit the lottery this is kind of like
hitting the line it is yeah
and and how should you react you know
what what's you know what what should
you be concentrating on it's too easy
like when
ball players get that first million
dollar check it just goes out you know
buy a car
and just blow the money in that you know
uh
this isn't how life is you know you
gotta
you you gotta be smart and uh too many
people don't know what
i'm old enough where i wouldn't go crazy
like that but
most these kids that suddenly are
sitting on hundreds of thousands of
dollars
that they didn't expect they don't know
what to do with it and a lot of them are
making mistakes because i hear a lot
about this
yeah well if you had any call to action
any anything you wanted to mention right
at the end this is your time that camera
right there
say what you want to that camera let's
see whatever you want yes my uh my main
focus
my main focus these days is our charity
foundation which is the aoki foundation
where we have blended brain health
and autism into one into uh
into under one umbrella and steve and i
work very hard on on this charity and
it's actually what
you know what means the world you know
to me now
we have a little beautiful autistic
daughter
we understand what you know what uh
is available to these kids and what
these kids need
and this is a very very valuable thing
that i feel
my remaining years i want to devote you
know to
autism and to brain health
and working with somebody like steve
aoki has been a godsend because he had
all the infrastructure
in place and and so we're you know we
have such a good thing going we have
events pokemon events
other types of events some business
things like what graham is going to be
involved with you know coming up in
a number of months uh anyway it's all
about charity and it's all
it's all about you know you know our
brain health and autism
aoki foundation dot org
yes so yeah anybody anybody that every
single donation means one therapy
session for a young kid
who will not get that therapy session
without it
thank you donate so with that
destroy it destroy that yeah like button
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
as always
smash the like button subscribe button
and notification bell feel free to add
us on instagram all the links are down
below in the description you can also
get four free stocks from weeble
it's all down below in the description
thank you guys so much for watching
really appreciate it and uh until next
time thank you guys
cool thank you we should do the mic drop
[Laughter]
uh
and also anything you mentioned is
perfectly fine too
you know anything you mentioned maybe
about this house or covid testing
anything you were to say is perfectly
fine
i don't get the most service in here but
here we go
all right i'll be super careful on the
mics
um and i have this
yeah perfect so we'll we'll do that
halfway through
the podcast is made uh 25 8 14.
so you're going to be introducing the
podcast what episode is this
is it the 32nd yeah i think the 31st
32nd
32nd i think yeah because we got jack
jordan so you're gonna say
welcome to the 30 30 second ever
episode of the iced coffee hour
introduce yourself
and then say the podcast has made so far
25 814
what was the first word again welcome to
the all you need to remember
32 30 second ever then 25
8 14. 32
32nd ever
what is b-roll oh we're going to get a
close-up of this
oh i see and then the b-roll is just
going to be recorded separately so i'm
going to put this
oh okay so jack i'm going to have you
stand
right here and just record sure
all right so just record this yes
that camera and
uh go is that the right side of the
roadside road facing you
go perfect